[Music]
on this monday night
what happened inside a quebec care home
the disturbing details and the owners
fight to stop
a public inquiry denouncing arbitrary
detentions of foreign nationals
i want to congratulate canada for
spearheading this initiative
the international declaration aimed at
china
protesters in myanmar threatened with
prison time
but they refused to give up their
demands for democracy plus the growing
online forums
for black people a lot of white people
aren't used to being the minority so
they don't understand how important it
is to have your own space
the need for safe spaces
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us we begin with the push to
protect canada's most vulnerable
from another deadly wave of coven 19.
across the country
public health authorities say they're
making progress in getting vaccines into
long-term care facilities
in some regions officials say there's
already proof the inoculations are
having an impact
we've also seen a notable decrease in
transmission
and outbreaks in long-term care and
assisted living facilities
as immunization has rolled out and this
is
clear evidence of the effectiveness of
the vaccines
and extremely encouraging news
for so many canadian families the
vaccine rollout is too little too late
according to the national institute on
aging more than 14 thousand canadians in
long-term care
have died of the virus of those more
than 7 600
were in quebec one of the province's
hardest hit facilities was heron
on montreal's west island dozens died in
horrible conditions
now a coroner's inquiry is underway to
determine
what went so wrong mike armstrong has
tonight's top story
the inquiry started basically with a
warning from the coroner
gan kemal says the proceedings will be
emotional for families who lost
loved ones and called for respect
now the plan is to begin the inquiry
with three days
looking at the heron residence in dorval
47 people died in the first wave of the
pandemic
in that one long-term care facility the
conditions inside the corner calls
indecent and inhumane in those first
weeks the staff was overwhelmed
and most left residents went for days
without being cleaned or properly fed
this social worker volunteered to help
and describe the chaos
inside there's a smell in there and it's
a smell
of the deceased and of wounds that need
to be
taken care of the goal of the inquiry is
to figure out what happened to
understand the mistakes to do that it
will have to determine the role covid19
played
and the role negligence may have played
lawyer patrick martijnal represents
four of the victims a lot has been said
that has been written about what has
been going on but this is the first
really public proceeding in which we
will really be able to ask
the key decision makers the questions
now the inquiry was supposed to hear
witnesses on day one
that didn't happen instead it was a day
of legal wrangling
the lawyers for the owners of the heron
residence are asking the hearings be
delayed
or covered by a publication ban they say
there's a criminal investigation
underway and their clients may face
charges over how the outbreak was
handled
if the inquiry goes on the lawyers say
it could be prejudicial against their
clients
the coroner suspended and will hand down
a decision tuesday
if it does continue the inquiry will
look at other residences in the coming
months
quebec recently passed 10 000 deaths
since the start of the pandemic
about 70 percent were in long-term care
centers
mike armstrong global news montreal
in ontario public health officials are
going to extraordinary lengths to try to
contain an outbreak of a variant first
detected in south africa
today health workers went floor by floor
at a mississauga condo building
offering everyone testing after five
people in the building tested positive
for the variant
and in newfoundland and labrador the
chief medical health officer is urging
people to be vigilant
after an outbreak of the variant first
discovered in the uk
the province says seven more people have
tested positive for the virus and 21
others are presumed
infected there are now 298
active cases in that province new coven
19 rules are now in effect
at canada's land border crossings as of
today non-essential travelers crossing
the u.s border into canada
must provide proof of a negative covet
19 test
taken within the last 72 hours people
who do not comply
face fines of up to three thousand
dollars or criminal prosecution
and starting february 22nd travelers
arriving by land
and air must also take a covenanting
test
upon arrival after weeks of setbacks and
shortages
it appears canada's vaccine deliveries
are finally set to ramp up
according to the federal public health
agency canada should get more than four
hundred thousand doses of the pfizer
biotech vaccine
this week that would be the biggest
shipment from that drug company so far
the next batch of modernity doses is
scheduled to arrive next week
the government says it's expecting 168
000 doses
that's tens of thousands less than what
was initially promised
canada's vaccine supply could soon get a
boost from india's
serum institute on twitter today the ceo
of the indian vaccine maker said doses
of the oxford astrazeneca vaccine
will be on route to canada in less than
a month last week
india's prime minister told our prime
minister that india would do its best
to supply canada with doses the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine is not yet approved
for use
in canada in the uk prime minister boris
johnson is applauding the nation's
unprecedented vaccination rollout at
least
15 million people have had their first
coven 19
shot and now the next phase begins but
johnson is tempering
expectations to help ease britain out of
lockdown
the number of people in hospitals
suffering from severe forms of the virus
is higher now than in the first wave of
the pandemic
here's our european chief crystal
gomezing with the health crisis
in one of the world's hardest hit
regions
with health officials moving on to a new
vaccination priority group
65 to 69 year olds british prime
minister boris johnson
has reason to be cheerful if you look at
what's happened in the last
few weeks it's been an unbelievable
effort by
the nhs national health service workers
pharmacists and members of the military
have
all been instrumental in the uk reaching
its goal
of 15 million jabs by mid-month
but the threat of the virus has not been
eased
british nationals arriving from red list
countries
mostly in south america and africa are
now being whisked off to 16 different
quarantine hotels we will be calling
every guest every day just to check if
there's anything we can get them is
there anything we can do for them
if there's any concerns that they have
but in addition to that there's also a
welfare
call provided by government imported
infections are of great concern
because of virus variants any positive
test from a traveler
will undergo genomic sequencing the more
transmissible variant first discovered
in the uk
led to a third lockdown for england
as the government praises its
vaccination achievements
it's countering calls to reopen saying a
timeline
will be shared next week i mean for me
making sure that we
oh you know as we lift measures we do so
carefully
and cautiously to make sure that we
don't have to
put them on again rates of infection
although they're coming down
are still comparatively high so we've
got to be very
prudent right prudent but
positive says johnson that things are
moving
in the right direction crystal gomansing
global news
london the federal government has
assembled a coalition of allies to
denounce state-sponsored arrests of four
nationals for political purpose
this is the strongest stance taken by
ottawa since the detention of two
canadians in china
the initiative is earning praise around
the world but as our chief political
correspondent david aiken reports
key countries are holding out
michael spavor and michael kovrig have
now been in chinese prisons for
798 days put there following the arrest
in canada
of mong wang zhou the chief financial
officer of chinese telecom giant huawei
who was wanted by the u.s on fraud
charges
ever since the two michaels were
detained canada has been putting
whatever diplomatic pressure it can on
china and monday's declaration may be
its most significant move yet
i'm grateful and emboldened by the
strong show of support here
today countries from every continent
stand together to tell people who are
being arbitrarily detained
abroad that they are not alone
the canadian-led declaration is endorsed
by 58 countries including
every other g7 member we need leadership
from rights respecting democracies if
the rule of law is to be restored
and promoted around the world so i want
to congratulate canada
for spearheading this initiative but
only two countries from china's
neighborhood japan and australia
would endorse the declaration canada is
working to have
others sign it too it's a very important
initiative
and canadians have been waiting quite a
long time for something
like this from the canadian government
and this one
is a really big deal as for china even
though it is not named in the
declaration
it appeared to get the hint and reacted
harshly
through its media mouthpiece the global
times the chinese government let it be
known it considers the declaration quote
an aggressive and ill-considered attack
designed to provoke china
and that canada's chosen diplomatic
approach has never worked before
and will not achieve any goal in the
future everybody's watching china now
to see what their reaction is going to
be whether they will
change their practices we all hope that
they will
um and that's the purpose of this whole
initiative
the next step for canada is to develop
some enforcement mechanisms to try to
put a little
teeth into this declaration and to keep
the pressure
on china robin david aiken in ottawa
thanks david
the impeachment trial of former u.s
president donald trump may be
over but trump has signaled that he
wants to remain an active force in
american politics
as jackson proskow reports with or
without trump
republicans now have to figure out what
kind of party
they want to be on this president's day
washington is still under tight guard
fearing more political uncertainty
at the hands of a newly exonerated
donald trump you will have no respect
for this
kind of soft norm of past presidents
letting their successors
do their job without interference donald
trump's not going to care about that
immediately following his acquittal
trump told followers
our historic patriotic and beautiful
movement to make america great again
has only just begun setting up a battle
between pro-trump republicans
and those who just want to move on the
republicans need to think about do we
want to be
a mainstream party or are we going to
fragments most republican voters have
gone
all in on trump believing his lie about
a stolen election
a poll found 66 percent of republicans
believe joe biden is an illegitimate
president
55 percent support the idea of using
force to slow what they see as a decline
in the traditional american way of life
his legacy will be certainly a permanent
change of the republican party to
becoming a more
nationalist populist party there are
signs
trump is no longer welcomed by the party
brass and won't find many friends if he
faces criminal charges
still liable for everything he did while
he's in office
didn't get away with anything yet there
are investigations underway into trump's
financial dealings
his attempts to overturn election
results in georgia
and his role in inciting the mob that
stormed the capital
any one of which could make trump a
political liability
for a party in recovery mode for now it
seems republicans are banking on trump
and his supporters to help them out in
the 2022 midterms
but whether the former president decides
to mount a comeback in 2024
is still a big unknown and will continue
to hang over the party
until he makes up his mind about what
he's going to do next
robin jackson proskun washington thanks
jackson
nearly 170 million americans are in the
path of a vicious weather system that
has caused some states to either declare
disasters
or states of emergency
an unusually wide band of frigid air has
triggered snow and ice
from seattle down to the deep south and
there are areas not used to extreme cold
in dallas where the temperature usually
hovers around six degrees celsius this
time of year
it dipped to minus -13 rolling power
blackouts have been ordered across texas
in oklahoma
people are also being asked to conserve
electricity through the cold snap
a huge winter storm dumped heavy snow
right across
that state demonstrators defied the
military's orders in myanmar
[Applause]
coming up the potential punishment if
they don't get off the streets
the military in myanmar also known as
burma is using a new weapon to crack
down on protesters
the junta imposed a law that threatens
up to 20 years in prison for
anyone convicted of obstructing the
armed forces
armored vehicles and soldiers are
patrolling the streets but demonstrators
remain defiant
fighting for the return of the country's
fragile democracy
redmond shannon reports
two weeks since the military coup and
the signs of unrest are only
increasing in myanmar a vigil for a 20
year old woman
shot in the head during clashes with
police now on life support
she is the most serious casualty of the
protests so far
across the ethnically diverse country
which is also known as burma
people are rallying against the return
to military rule
they were flanked on monday by armoured
vehicles
as the military increased its presence
on the streets
the new rulers are also introducing a
law to monitor online activity
and they're threatening anyone
obstructing armed forces with
up to 20 years in prison but many are
defying those threats
this man said this is a peaceful protest
we are fighting for the freedom of
government staff
but more so they want freedom for the
country's deposed leader aung
suchi she was due in court monday but
her lawyer says that will now take place
wednesday the charges against her
include illegal possession of six
walkie-talkies the nobel peace prize
winner easily won last year's elections
the military alleges voter fraud her
popularity is despite international
condemnation of the country's deadly
persecution
of rohingya muslims since 2017. the
military never
actually totally stepped away from power
you know during the so-called transition
to democracy it was never a genuine
transition to full democracy
the military's position in government
has been baked into democratic reforms
made a decade ago so far the response
from the international community
has been very weak it's mostly amounted
to
statements of concern and condemnation
and we really need to move beyond
that to get some practical action human
rights groups say
other nations should target the
military's money by restricting foreign
investment to companies controlled by
the armed forces redmond shannon global
news london
still ahead the online space is helping
canada's black community connect
and why there's a growing demand
the black lives matter protest of last
summer following the death of george
floyd sparked a racial reckoning
the movement forced canadians to examine
the issues and obstacles people of color
face
every day in this country and for the
black community
black only spaces on youtube facebook
and other social media sites
have emerged as forums to address
concerns and to heal
the purpose of these spaces isn't to
exclude anyone but to offer a platform
to connect over shared experiences
candice daniel explains i remember every
time when i went to swimming lessons
it was my hair for kimberly west her
anxieties around the pool
started at a young age i would be in a
class
all the other kids are white and when
they're finished swimming
they got to just leave when i was
finished swimming my hair was now
a big puff the struggle is real for
black women
and girls who want to swim and it's a
concern
only they know the chlorine and the
extreme heat
typically used for styling black hair
creates a recipe for damage
that can cause breakage and hair loss so
for most black women
there's no such thing as a quick dip in
the pool
her experience inspired kimberly to
create
black women swim a facebook group where
black women can find classes
and share their fears about the water
because the next generation needs to see
us swimming
so that it becomes that much easier for
them to be willing to swim as well
there is a growing number of black only
spaces that provide the community with
the freedom to create
express themselves and to network
tenille spencer
has been running a t-shirt business for
four years and believes these spaces are
important
to help other black entrepreneurs so
it's not about
you know division it's about supporting
those who need it the most
and i would think that everyone in the
one in the community would want to do
the same
i'm also someone who's lived this
experience and can speak to
my lived experience of it khadija
imboi's youtube channel has grown from
97 subscribers in june to more than 180
000 followers today she tackles social
issues like racial bias
colorism and privilege having black only
spaces
it gives the black people in them the
space to not only explore who they are
meet other people enjoy whatever but
also to not feel like they're being
watched
and the open exchange with her audience
has given her channel the momentum
to keep growing a lot of black people
that i know especially in the comments
that i get on a lot of the videos
so many of them are black women that are
just like oh my god thank you
kimberly west's facebook page is still
growing but she hopes others know
it's a space to share experiences and
let's actually demonstrate and try to
go against the stereotype that black
women don't swim creating a greater
sense of awareness
and an opportunity for black canadians
to let their hair down
and even get it wet if they want to
candice daniel
global news toronto
that story is part of global's new
online initiative called perspectives
the site features stories reflecting
canada's diverse population
check it out at globalnews.ca
perspectives
is it over yet the world's longest
hockey game
next
you'd better bundle up if you live in
southern parts of saskatchewan and
manitoba
environment canada warns the wind chill
could make it feel like minus 45
tonight heavy snow is also expected to
blanket southern quebec by morning
there are winter storm warnings from bc
right through to newfoundland
and labrador it's freezing in alberta as
well but that didn't stop a group of
hockey players near edmonton from
braving the bitter cold
to set a record for the world's longest
hockey game
[Applause]
the around-the-clock game lasted 252
hours and finished at 6am this morning
40 players risked frostbite in
temperatures that plunged to minus 40.
it was so cold at one point pucks
shattered
and skate blades snapped in two i'm very
proud of
the the people that rallied around and
did everything that was necessary to
make this happen
it was a it was a bit of a skeleton crew
this year
the event has raised 1.84 million
dollars and counting
the money will help support cancer
research at the university of alberta
and that is global national for this
monday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is this hot air
balloon over high river
alberta thank you for watching donna
friesen will be back here tomorrow
have a great night
[Music]
you